zach allen
in a season where the rotation has given
very few innings zach gallon has been
the guy to take the ball and do what he
needs to do 21 consecutive starts to
begin his career three runs or earn runs
or fewer ties a major league record
and we are set to go on jackie robinson
day from phoenix arizona and mikey
stremski leads it off for the giants
off the mound
high hop for nick ahmed away
slumping alex dickerson as the giants
left fielder zach on the attack with
fastballs in the zone
popped up third base side for escobar
two down and that'll bring up evan
longoria hit back up the middle slowed
down by
the pitcher gallon and then trying to
bare hand it was mark tay in longoria
has got a hit here comes the red hot
brandon belt this is the most dangerous
hitter in the giants lineup right now
and belt takes ball four so two men on
with two outs and wilmer flores will
come up who was red hot last week but
has since cooled off and a breaking ball
gets him swinging so gallon gets his
first strikeout the giants send out
tyler anderson one-on-one this year at
3-4-5 era really dominated the
diamondbacks in san fran a three-hit
shutout swing in the miss on a change-up
he struck him out here could tell marta
he is in a four for 24 skid right now
been a little quiet lately well bill
miller called him out but he's still got
another strike to go
i like it that martay can laugh about it
martay sends one toward left center
field dickerson on the run he won't get
there it's over the wall for a ground
rule double we're all dwell that ends
well so here is starling martay could
tell it's second and one out and there's
a shot to left that ball is going to get
down for a hit could tell around third
being waved home one-nothing
diamondbacks on an rbi single by starley
marte zach gallon's got a run to work
with as he pitches here in the second
donovan solano leading off for the
giants breaking ball and a swing and a
miss and for gallon second strikeout two
down and joey parker got him looking and
that'll end the ending two strikeouts
the giants go down in order to shut down
inning there for gallon bases are loaded
nobody out and the third place hitter
the very dangerous starling marte comes
up change up and it's popped up shallow
left field crawford racing out crawford
over the shoulder makes a catch what a
nice play by brandon crawford well we've
seen that so many times over the years
there may not be a player in baseball
who makes that play better than crawford
that's a big first out walker will be
the banner with the bases loaded now one
up walker hits a fly ball to dickerson
in left field drifting near the line
carson kelly at third here he comes rbi
for walker
and it's two-nothing diamondback i'm
kind of looking for a few more runs in
this inning maybe probably can do
something about that here and a shot
base hit left center field right through
the shift into score is le castro it's a
two-run third inning a three-nothing
diamondback lead now the banners eduardo
escobar with runners at second and third
escobar hits a high pop-up on the
infield left side crawford the shortstop
underneath it looks up reaches up and
makes the catch that is out number three
diamondbacks had the bases loaded nobody
out and they scored two castro is at
second base could tell at first nobody
on there's starling that's gonna get
into left center here comes le castro he
will score another rbi for starling
martay making four-nothing d-bats still
no outs in the fifth and here is
christian walker walker tries to dunk
one into center it drops into shallow
right center here comes cattell he will
score it's five nothing diamondbacks
another throw to first gets away from
bell here comes starling he's gonna
score six nothing diamondbacks here's
ahmed now with two outs ahmed sends one
toward the corner and that's gonna get
down for extra bases it's in the bullpen
making an rbi double for nick and it's
seven nothing diamondbacks
chew down nobody on and longoria will
come up now the 1-0 pitch curve ball is
swung on and hit deep down the left
field line if it's fair it's gone it is
hooking and it is gone a home run we
haven't seen many mistakes from gallon
and that certainly was and longoria
jumped on it it's 7-1 here come the
giants first and third one out with joey
bart coming to the plate zach allen has
been really good with runners on base
seems like that's when he's at his best
jammed him that might dunk in there and
hope starling's under it solano will
have to hold at third nice pablo
sandoval will hit two on and two out
there's a soft fly ball to right and
martay with a leapy catch
to make the grab and save a run in the
end a nice play by marty it is a triple
for brandon bell here is wilmer flores
fastball that ball is hammered deep into
left-center field and off the base of
the wall coming in to score his belt
going to second is flores with a double
and a run batted in and it is seven to
two arizona
crawford hits a high fly ball to right
lecastro back
out of here
and crawford knocks one out of the park
it's a two-run home run and it's 7-4
and that'll get it done cattell marte is
there seven for the final and the
diamondbacks snapped that eight-game
losing streak